ていた
[音楽]
ダーク空が作るぞ
望岳借りすぎでやばいですもう来た来た来ました
ああ
バッハ
持った
今日はやばい
ウェルがやめろたぞ
今回は動物園動物園
[音楽]
ねこれジョイントミスったらとびだせどうぶつの森を飛び出さないですね
またん
goo
ポポッコカーンああ
ありがとうございます
ええええええ
me
こんにちははじめ社長です
ベッドを買いました
嘘ですはいというわけですねあのー
ライオンてかっこいいじゃないですからいよんかっこよくてちょっと一時的でもいい
けど家においてみたいなぁと思って火4君今日は来てもらいましたーーー
いい金パラもう大人しいもう遅いしてますからね今だッ
ムシですねはいでなかなか出ないヨンエにおけるのって難しいんですけどもなんと滑る
の許可をとって大家さんの許可もっとに専門家に起きていただいて万全の状態で
ライオン君を迎え入れておりますそれでも抜けだ絶対明日僕ネットニュースのトップに
なってると思うんで絶対逃げ出さないようにしてあるので安心して下さいねっ
ああそうですね
ああああああうん
[音楽]
もう食べとるの食べてるなう
かわいい
よく見るとほぼ猫なんですよね
ねえ声はやっぱり入ってゆけでこんなに可愛い来洋風なんですけどもう
とっきーしようと思います発赤そこ道路なんですけども道路あろうとていきなりこう
すれちがうトライ様がいるドッキリ
やっていこうと思いますはいというわけで早速が仕掛けていきましょうどうしていける
かと言いますとねここにあるいはいるんですけどもターゲットかこっちから歩いて来て
ちょうどここを
遠くただ内容が違うっていうイメージですねここに実は李前議員さん入ってしてるんで
ここに気を取られて上見てたらパッと出てくるっていう作戦です
ガッツで多分普通に考えて家にライオンいるのまずで来いと思うんですよおそらく
クズ男体協のブッティなるのではないでしょうかではターゲットを待ちましょう
ています
グッドガール
[音楽]
wh
要望
あっはぁん
だけでわーっ
レイヤー4がいるドッキリですなぁ4ボイスつ
走っ
語彙力ボイルド訳すですごくない予防複素幾何金さんあんまり意味なさそうなんで普通
に歩くだけでも見ると思うね歩いて来てもらいます組
[音楽]
マミえ持っ連星
view びっくりしましたよそうですねはい
[音楽]
ウソでしょこの辺が良かった良かったんですよ
の
hey えっ甲冑ドコモですか本物です
やばいやばいやばいやばいやばいれません
組合ってどっ
[音楽]
復活していません
分
[音楽]
こういうん
ピックって
ん
me
[音楽]
どうああ
ああああああああ
アップわぁああああああ ano
おおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおお
おおおおおおおおおおお
uh
ni
me
あっあっはぁ
[拍手]
わー
元二弾
あっはい